hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
Shadow of the Colossus is an absolute
masterpiece but it can be easy to get a
little stuck to help out here's a
complete guide to all 16 of the colossi
I'll let you know the differences
between normal and hard modes and the
best strategy for Time Attack modes
every battle is time-stamped below so if
you're ready let's do this
the first to colossi are really trading
mode but let's cover them all the same
Valis is the first beast will be cooling
and it's pretty self-explanatory
hop on his left foot and stab his calf
to cause him to fall as we climb up
you'll see a weak fight on his right arm
that's only there for the hard mode it's
easier to fall down to this from his
head so we'll leave it there for the
time being once you're on the beasts
crown charge your blade and get a few
hits in if you need to regen any stamina
hang back on the top of his spine and
rest for a while
then return to the task at hand if you
fall off at any point simply start the
process again by hitting his weak spot
on his left calf but if you're in Time
Attack mode you can't afford to lose
time mounting the Beast more than once
at this point the normal version is
complete but those of us on hard will
need to fall down valises back and onto
his arm use the platform to fully
regenerate your stamina especially in
Time Attack mode as you'll need to take
out this digital in one sitting
easy now onto the next one
quadratus is next up colossus number two
and will require your bowl right away
circle around to the back of the beast
and you'll see the weak spot under its
feet blast one of these to cause it to
stumble
go around to the leg that was shot and
find fur to grab and begin to climb to
the top if you ever fall off simply do
that step again and to continue the
sigil on his side is for the hard mode
that's going to be our last place of
interest we're going to start with the
one which is over his books this is
another which requires attention to your
stamina meter at any point you hear the
clicking noise try to find a safe place
to stand and regenerate of course in the
story mode if you ever have issues with
stamina search out those lizards across
the land and pick up their tails after
killing them that will give you
additional stamina once this vigil is
successfully slaughtered we can walk
across the monsters back and repeat the
formula on its head he's a bit of a
Thrasher so get to a safe place if you
need recovery time at this point on
normal mode you are done but for hard
mode there is just one more signal which
we've already seen on his side walk
across his back to fully gain stamina
and then drop down into position and
slow the Beast
Colossus number three Gaius is probably
going to cause a few issues when the
battle starts
I recommend spamming him full of arrows
and hopefully hitting a weak area like
the [ __ ] stamp on his navel
we're staying still for a reason we are
moving him over here because we need to
make room to use that metal plate behind
him once he begins his attack animation
get your backside over to the metal ring
opposite we're trying to make him break
his own armor by hitting this metal slug
with a powerful sword hit so stay here
as long as you dare then jump or dive
out of the way
jumping back is the most reliable option
in my eyes now with his armor in tatters
we can mount him and the best way to do
this is to use his sword once his next
attack comes in dive away and quickly
run of his sword this didn't go
according to plan for me but I'm keeping
it in to show you that it's okay if the
perfect plan goes wrong like always
remember how you got up here as you'll
need to do the same thing again should
you fall off we are going all the way up
to his head and working down the attack
zones use the top of his spine for a
rest and regen area for your stamina and
those on time attack mode don't risk
anything back off and gain stamina
whenever you need it the heart of the
difficulty the Mothe rushing about
you'll need to cling on through but keep
chipping away and you'll get the job
done next we're going for the hard mode
sigil on his left elbow that was on
Normal difficulty he'll straight down
his back and round to the front for your
final stab fest on time attack mode it's
important to have full stamina before
dropping down to this area we want this
out of the way in a single visit if
possible if you're unsure you can get
back up just don't risk it climb to a
safe spot and regen your stamina with
that complete it's a simple drop to the
stomach area but I over pushed it and I
fell off but I wanted to keep this in to
show you that it's not the end of the
world stay calm retrace your steps and
get to the final weak point and go to
town job
[Music]
the fourth Colossus is horrible as it
holds a random element which you cannot
control in the slightest you'll be
waiting an awful lot in this fight
meet Phaedra she's an inquisitive little
beast which is her downfall
jump on your horse and travel to any of
the dogs in the telly tubby house nearby
use your arrows to gain her attention
and then disappear into the building
when she approaches resurface at one of
the other doors but do not let her see
you after what feels like forever she
will begin to look inside the doors and
this is your moment to strike climb up
her butt bone for one of a better phrase
but be warned this can be a glitchy mess
if that doesn't work for you grab the
tassels on her head and climb there
instead once on board climb to her
shoulders and regenerate your stamina on
normal mode it's possible to kill the
Beast with only headshots so you guys go
straight up there and finish this but
those on hard mode you need to weak in
two areas first on each of her shoulders
are additional sigils to destroy it's
nothing too taxing though like usual pay
attention to your stamina drop down
destroy rinse and repeat
now get back onto her shoulders and
you'll see a vital point to trigger the
final sigil you know what to do to
finish the fight climb on Phaedrus head
and finish their job
hello sis number five is Avion Avion
Avion and it's the same for normal and
hard versions only the number of sword
stabs will change here get your backside
over to the three platforms and stand on
the middle one take out your bow and
officially start the fight and get
areum's attention as he swoops in jump
and grab his fur and hold on for dear
life your job is to slowly make it to
the end of each wing before taking out
his tail it isn't too complicated and
extremely easy if you have an abundance
of stamina wait until he flies straight
and run to the end of the wing do as
much damage as you can and then run
straight across to the second wing once
both wings are taken care of make your
way to the tail and finish the job
the sixth colossi is barber and the
first thing we need to do is run away
like the scared wimp we are after about
30 seconds of running you'll find this
hiding spot stand on the plinth
underneath it's the perfect position
once the Beast has finished smashing
everything in sight he'll bend down to
try and spot you in future we're going
to climb on his lovely sexy beard but
the first thing we're going to do is get
the additional hardmode sigil out of the
way it's on his hand as he peers in run
out and get on top of his hand charge
your blade and wipe this out as quickly
as possible
doing this now means he won't shake as
much so I recommend taking it out first
next drop off and repeat the steps but
this time used that sexy beard to
traverse up high he's another Thrasher
so once again get yourself onto his
spine to regen stamina before going into
battle with his skull with that out of
the way you will now need to drop down
to the lower left side of his back this
can be quite unpleasant depending on how
much thrashing he does but if the worst
comes to the worst and you fall off go
through the actions again and down this
big bastard
hydrous is colossi number seven and is
the same on both normal and hard
difficulties as the battle starts we are
desperately trying to get its attention
by swimming above it once his eyes turn
red you know the fight will ensue
shortly as hydrous comes to the surface
try to get near without being
electrocuted by the barbs do this well
and the tail will push you out of the
water long enough to grab hold of it
from here it's a case of running up the
tail when out of the water and holding
on for dear life went under the waves
you'll finally catch up with one of
those electric barbs either run in and
attempt to hit the weak point to
deactivate it immediately or keep your
distance and wait for the electric shock
to pass then jump in and hit the
pressure point both techniques are
completely fine continue at the spine
and take out the next pressure point on
the electric Bob rinse and repeat one
more time until you make it to the head
and then take out the Beast if you're
doing swimmingly well it's possible to
do this in one phase but don't worry if
that doesn't happen repeat all the steps
get the beasts attention position
yourself ready to grab the tail if
you've taken out the electric Barb's
this becomes even easier run up the
spine where possible and finish the
fight oh but be careful of this bloody
bobbing motion at the beasts head I
recommend holding r2 and crawling up to
finish the fight
fact number eight is with the kuru Mori
and is probably my favorite fight in the
game once again this battle is the same
on normal and hard
although the poison projectiles on hard
are extremely potent so beware as soon
as the fight begins whistle for your
horse we are trying to get the attention
of the kuru Mori so it climbs up to this
level and whistling is the perfect way
to do this from here throw yourself down
to the ground I tend to Leap near walls
and hold r2 to grab ledges on the way
down
negating any damage I take once on the
ground you'll need to use your bow to
take out two of the Kouros legs before
it hits you with its own attacks if you
get your shot on target it will cancel
his attacks but if you miss reposition
quickly and try again then watch him
fall depending on how far he falls will
dictate how long this damage phase will
last that's why we whistled from the
very top so we could absolutely wreck
him in the opening cycle it's possible
that the Kuro will crush you when
rolling back to his feast so I bailed
out probably a little too early here
better to be safe than sorry I suppose
now we run as far up the Colosseum as we
dare and whistle for attention on the
way try to give him enough time to climb
higher or once you're back on the ground
he'll be too close to fire arrow safely
at our worst still like in my run once
he's fallen the damage phase is far too
short to do any decent damage luckily
for me I had time to do one more cycle
and I didn't fluff my arrows too much
job done
fights number nine is with the bass
Aaron and is the same on normal and hard
difficulties he'll fire but loads of
flaming projectiles at you I'll try to
stick around here so you can see one
bago we're going to use the environment
to help expose his weaknesses
these keys are like things are our
friends position yourself quite far away
from one of the geezers and hope that
the bass around walks over it if done
correctly the pressure from the geezer
will cause him to lose his balance so
then we run in and shoot arrows at the
green pods on the two crooked legs
causing him to fall onto his back run
all the way round to the opposite side
and clamber up his fern
once near the top of the bus around will
regain his faculties and write himself
we want to be on his shell if possible
but beware prepare for a very bumpy ride
make your way to the head of the beast
and not the back side like I did and
absolutely smash his skull to pieces
due to the flat angle your stamina will
pretty much not run out so go crazy like
the murderous love you are and ends the
fight as quick as you can
[Music]
Colossus number 10 is the sand snake
dirge which is principally the same on
normal and hard difficulties as the
fight begins get on your horse and take
out your bow once up to speed
hold triangle to maintain your velocity
ride around in circles until dirge
begins to follow as his eyes pop out of
the sand take aim with your bow and hit
one of them with an arrow
this will cause dirge to become blinded
and smash straight into the nearest wall
simply climb off his back and take out
the first sigil before he comes back
around once again it's a case of rinse
and repeat but hopefully your horse
isn't as inbred as mine and you can
reach that'll quickly
follow the same steps and remember to
take out your sod to locate the last
digit pretty easy fight if your horse
doesn't go into full [ __ ] mode
[Music]
Colossus number 11 is the hound celosia
and we're going to use a trick from the
ps2 days to take a minute out of our
time here fire is the only way to remove
cell osseous armor so as soon as
possible climb up onto one of the fire
pits the Colossus will charge at the
pillar causing a flaming stick to fall
by the way if you jump at the right time
you won't lose your footing or suffer
any damage our job now is to take that
stick and reignite it it's easier said
than done err this mutt will wreck you
at every chance it gets once the stick
is on fire use it to push back the
Colossus to the edge of the cliff as you
can see this is really time-consuming so
we can glitch this to a degree run over
to the cliff edge and take out your
sword then immediately pick the stick up
again this will skip that entire
sequence and open up the sigil on
selassie is back depending on where you
are after the cutscene you can jump
straight on its back and finish the
fight quickly if you find yourself out
of position like I am jump on the beasts
back and start stabbing the sigil as
often as you can if you do get knocked
off don't worry
regen your stamina and jump straight
back on again
[Music]
[Music]
the twelfth colossi is Pelageya who is a
water beast this fight is the same on
normal and hard difficulties when you
regain control of wonder swim to the
back of the beast and climb up the mossy
grass once on the crown of the beast use
these teeth like things to direct the
animal to any of the structures in the
water once close enough jump onto the
structure and hide behind the central
column as the Colossus will attack
sometimes it's instantly sometimes it's
after a short wait so don't take the
chance get behind the pillar
next the Beast will rear up and look for
you this is your chance to jump onto its
belly and try to get three solid hits in
be careful here the hit detection can be
quite terrible and only take off a
morsel of life the best thing you can do
is line up as centrally as you can on
the sigil after that short window is
complete the Beast resubmits and the
process starts again swim to the back
climb to the head use the teeth to
direct the Beast jump onto the structure
hide from the blast leap onto the
stomach stab stab stab pretty boring but
you'll get there
Colossus number 13 is the phalanx and
this is the same on normal and hard
difficulties as the scrap begins take
out your bow and attempt to puncture all
three air sacs keeping the beast in the
air
I'm personally terrible with a bow and
was forced to jump on my horse to get
close enough to hit all three sacks next
the Phalanx will lose altitude and dip
its front wings into the ground our task
is to grab hold of those wings easier
said than done but keep trying and you
will get it it's best to be on the back
of the two wings but any will do once
the Phalanx is back in the air
run to the first sigil but do not
destroy it completely once any of the
sigils are destroyed the phalanx
regularly barrel rolls so we want to
prevent Star Fox from happening as long
as possible now we'll run down the tail
utilizing a jump to propel further until
you've reached the second sigil same
again don't destroy it we don't want to
barrel roll and then from here travel
down the tail again until you see the
third sigil this time we can destroy it
go for it and like we said the barrel
rolls begin you'll also notice that the
other two sigils are now blocked by
scales the Phalanx will knock you off
and we start again shoot the three air
sacs climb above the wings once in the
air find the closest is you'll destroy
it survive the barrel rolls run down the
tail to the second sigil and end the
fight done and dusted
[Music]
Zenobia is the 14th colossus will be
facing and once again both normal and
hard modes are the same we first need to
complete a jumping puzzle to knock off
the armor so as the fight begins jump on
the closest fallen pillar and follow
this route once the top of these high
pillars we need interactions from
shinobi ax who will try to knock us off
remember to hold r2 in these moments
after the first hit fire an arrow at the
mutt as sometimes he can get locked in
an animation loop and occasionally he
even runs away and never returns so it's
quite important to shoot arrows at him
every so often as the pillar falls jump
to the next ledge it's really that
simple
I won't patronize you here I'll speed up
the clip just in case you want to see
the full run
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
once this pillar Falls we can get into
position to take out shinobi as armor
[Music]
run around to this specific pillar and
aggro the dog into smashing it to pieces
now it's a case of getting on his back
and wailing around this can be done by
jumping on his back but it's better to
let them now unprotected beast briefly
knock itself out by running into the
pillars you're stood on once you're in
stab mode on his back you may find that
he knocks you off using ledges but don't
worry about this simply get up get on
one of the Fallen pillars close by and
wait for the idiot to knock himself out
again a surprisingly easy
[Music]
Colossus number 15 is probably the
hardest fight in the game and it's due
to the additional damage point in hard
mode meet Argus the additional point is
where his heart is so if you're playing
a normal you can skip the hardest part
of the fight
once the encounter begins run over to
this part of the map there's a Ledge
that's slightly out of reach so we'll
need this Colossus to stamp two boosters
up to the next level whilst waiting it's
a great tactic to take out your bow and
fire at Agassi's weak points
that's his head and his heart although
the heart is only part of the hard mode
as he approaches and lifts his foot time
jumping away and being off the ground
when his foot lands this will negate any
damage you take and the stumble
animation - and quickly turn around and
use the heightened ledge to jump to the
next level inside here
take out your ball whilst waiting and
keep attacking those weak points as and
when you see the next attack animation
begin dive to your left or right to
avoid damage once again this has helped
us reach the next level in the structure
from here we can run to either bridge
once on top go crazy with your boat his
where things can change slightly
Auguste will smash down the bridge with
his sword but he often walked too far
before doing so if you choose to you can
use your boat to hit the vital point on
his elbow forcing him to drop his sword
and also revealing his hidden sigil
which we also need to destroy whatever
your choice your next job is to jump on
top of the Colossus and begin to destroy
his crown he will thrash uncontrollably
at time so take regular stamina breaks
on his shoulders
if you're playing on how difficulty
we'll take the hardest element now the
additional sigil on Argos is heart
there's no easy way to do this you'll
need to drop down into position and hope
the Colossus stay still for long enough
to attack you'll need to climb back up
regularly to reset your stamina and if
you fall off you can get back up using
the same strategy from before but you
will still need Argos to give you a leg
up to the first step with those two
elements out of the way it's time to
finish the bite if you haven't removed
your foes sword yet then make your way
down his arm to hit the weak point until
he drops it now fall to the ground and
hope for the correct animation Argos
will attempt to stamp on you or hit you
with his fist it's the latter one that
we want as his fist flies towards you
dive out of the way then quickly run
into his palm and hold on for dear life
eventually he'll give you enough time to
finish the bite
[Applause]
and finally malice the last of the
colossi this skirt wearing explosive
throwing British Alps has a single
difficult area which will cause issues
but we'll talk about that when we get
there the first part of the fight is all
about closing the gap and surviving the
bombs the route is pretty obvious moving
from cover to cover and utilizing
underground passages even if you are hit
as long as you aren't blown off the map
it's pretty easy to get back on side
once you've made it to the feet of the
beast slowly make your way up to his
back nothing can hurt you here it's all
platforming
now the action can begin hit the vital
point as much as you like to caused
malice to bring his hand around
from here jump onto the hand and hold on
try to maneuver yourself around the
wrist area which will allow you to run
straight up his forearm to the next
point
take this opportunity to damage his
bicep which is also a vital point you'll
notice a hand to jump to
[Music]
this can be quite a tricky jump but it's
possible to just let go and balance on a
piece of bomber before jumping across to
the hunt
once on malice is hand tried to get
around to the back of the hand for the
hardest section of the fight to give
yourself more time stab his hand
regularly
once in this position take out your bow
and hit his shoulder there's a vital
point there this is easily the most
pressure you will feel in any fight so
be ready to grab r2 and stay hold of the
hand as it swings over to the shoulder
from here you can go straight to the
head if you want to but I recommend
hitting the vital point a few times to
bring down his health bar now it's time
to end the game who make your way up to
the head and prepare to be thrown around
like you're in a mosh pit but keep hold
watch your stamina and bring it home
a few stubs later this journey is all
that's it all sixteen colossi or
Colossus assists if you prefer done and
dusted
oh well flee I do hope this was useful
to you and your journey through such a
bloody great game if you have any tips
for anyone please put them in the
comments below and let's find ways to
optimize each fight
I am Adam from Playstation grenade this
has been an absolute pleasure thank you
for your time I'll see you soon